what's up everyone currently in Flores
and Natalia and as you can see here I'm
standing next to a automatic and
automated cashier stand here you just
touch and enter in what items you want
it eliminates the need in use of a
cashier swipe your card right there and
just like that we are getting rid of a
huge portion of the labor costs
associated cashiers and the food is just
brought it's still made by humans for
now but just like that we are slowly it
says the McDonald's said by 2020 they
would eliminate all cashiers with these
automated checkouts then boom just like
that here we see one in Florence already
up and running so just a heads up for
those that are cashiers right now it is
time to refrain that means go and take
new classes get new work of jobs that
are more secure for jobs that have a
longer longevity it's very important to
retrain now and to not wait any longer
you are a cashier and that means be
aware of the age of automation because
here we are right here again automated
checkouts at McDonald's already up in
they're visible around other places in
the world as well this one's in Florence
in Italia so heads up get new work
Automation age is coming much love
everyone